hello
i'm michelle i'm a volunteer at raley
windmill
today we're going to talk about the
exhibition that's on the second floor of
the mill
the flower sack was a lucky find
the thatcher at the dutch cottage
mentioned to a volunteer that he had a
flower sack from the
windmill in his barn and was happy to
donate it
several small donations paid for the
restoration
the sack would have been used to hold
grain
or flour and when full would have
weighed about 200 pounds
donations have paid largely for the
items that are in the exhibition
one of the donations came from the
estate of thelma passfield
thelma and her family had lived in a
house in the grounds of the windmill
her father was a carton pear driver
there were a pair of suffolk punches
some shy horses a rather grumpy
donkey and a lively pony
another donation has come from one of
our volunteers
james crabb was the last miller under
windsail at raley mill
he was miller from 1888 to around
the early 1900s he retired at an early
age due to being unable to carry out a
full working week
that would have been six days then this
may have been due to miller's cough
but we're not sure he died in 1917.
beside the photo of james crabb you can
see
a small seed drill this would have been
used
to sow seeds in maybe an allotment
a garden or something like that
in the photo of james crabb you can see
that he's holding a sack barrow
there's a full-size example which forms
part of the exhibition
looking forward to seeing you when we're
open again
we have lots to show you in this
exhibition